the town hall in paris 15th district
a new batch of covid vaccines arrives
inside a doctor measures out doses ready
for use
elderly people are being prioritized for
immunization
those here are hopeful that life may
soon return to normal
i'm just desperate to do things again i
feel like i've been stagnating
and i couldn't wait to have this vaccine
the goal is that everyone is vaccinated
as fast as possible so the virus recedes
as the number of people vaccinated
against covid in france grows
so does talk of a vaccine passport to
travel
this french politician says such a
document could also be used to visit
restaurants or theaters
those who are vaccinated should be able
to resume activities
the vaccination passport would show that
a person is no longer in danger
themselves and no longer a danger to
others
supporters of a vaccine passport say
could help revive
vital economic sectors like tourism
paris
is usually one of the world's most
visited cities but
in the past year few people have come to
admire its monuments
or enjoy attractions like this cruise
the owner of this boat tour company
on the river sends says he would welcome
a vaccine passport
it would encourage international
travelers to return to the city because
without them
it will be a challenge to keep the
business afloat
any solutions that can help us live
normally again would be good
there are already countries that require
vaccinations to enter
so a vaccine passport is a good idea if
it can help
everyone work again opinion polls
suggest that a majority of people in
france support
a vaccine passport for travel or access
to certain services
but the french government says it's far
too early to consider such a measure
that it would be divisive because not
enough people have been immunized
and many don't wish to be it would be
unfair and especially in france where we
have you know this uh
we are very well attached to the
equality principles so
exactly it could be the reaction could
be okay
only the first people to be vaccinated
will have those rights
and not ourselves none and we have to
queue we have to wait for a while before
getting vaccinated so it's unfair eu
leaders will discuss the idea of a
vaccine passport during a meeting
thursday the issue divides member states
it's clear though that opening up
economies and offering some freedoms
won't be easy
while the eu's still navigating its
worst ever health emergency
natasha butler al jazeera paris